that right there is Michael B Jordan's
sweet birthday video post to his
girlfriend Lori Harvey I think I'm a
pretty lovable guy actually the 34 year
old actor shared this clip on Instagram
of the two on the beach as they bend
their heads together and plan their
football strategy
Michael's arm and Lori's catch made for
quite the impressive play not to mention
a rare PDA moment for the couple
in the caption Michael calls out his
Leading Lady using a cute nickname
writing quote happy b-day to my turtle
my favorite partner in crime the Creed
star also shows fans the aftermath of
the big game posting a selfie to a story
of the pair napping in the sun together
Michael writes all that winning got you
tired I'm just genuinely excited now the
Black Panther star has been celebrating
Lori's 25th birthday all week the first
of her celebrations a surprise party
thrown by Michael himself
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
[Laughter]
and although the actor couldn't attend
he made sure Lori was surrounded by her
closest girlfriends including Normani
and Ryan Destiny super proud of that yes
then on Thursday the skin by LH founder
shared on Instagram that her family
threw her a last-minute house party
which Michael was able to attend Lori
reveals guests were greeted by a black
and gold 25 balloon Archway display and
give an LH branded Black Sweat sets and
that's her mom Marjorie Harvey showing
off her dance moves on the colorful lit
up dance floor there's been lots of
celebrating in the recent months for
Michael and Laurie in November the
couple marked their one year anniversary
together and when ET spoke with the just
Mercy star earlier that year he opened
up about their romance what does Michael
B Jordan find very sexy
um that's a good one uh I think it's
I think a sense of humor I think you
know the ability to laugh you know that
infectious feeling I think is I think
it's really really sexy so a smile a
nice smile and a laugh and a sense of
humor is uh is really sexy to me well I
see why you found who you found then
because she has all of those all those
things absolutely actually very funny a
lot of people don't know that about it
yeah it's just really fun yeah it makes
me so happy I appreciate it people that
know me it's like that's that's like the
common like uh you know feeling so yeah
I know y'all I thought I was so lonely
before I felt that bad about me but
thank you glad y'all see me happy I
appreciate it
foreign